Do you know that the roller coaster as we know it now is truly an evolutionary thing?
It was originally an ice slide.
And even though we don't think of it as doing the luge,...
...at one time in Eastern Europe, that's what they did.
They had these slides that went up and down the hills,...
...and they were packed with ice.
And that's how they had all of the daring and exciting ride that you get with the roller coaster.
It's the exhilaration and the feel of the speed that people like.
And then, once it went to France and some other places that were in Southern Europe...
...and didn't have so much ice and snow,...
...someone had to come up with a way of making a rail for this inclined plane with a car.
And then it became the roller coaster.
And now with the history of Coney Island in the United States and many other places,...
...the thing that an amusement park is known for is its roller coaster.
Oftentimes, roller coasters are made of the wood base.
Many times they're made with steel.
Now, they get into the "loop the loop" kind of things.
And they go for going backwards as well as forwards.
There's a very, very big following for roller coasters.
Oftentimes, people are parts of clubs that keep track of which roller coasters they've ridden on...
...and which ones are the most famous, and how many roller coasters a certain amusement park has.
It's often a big draw for the tourist.